اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل شخص
واصابه خمسه وعشرين مواطنا على الاقل وذلك
برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه خلال اقتحامها
البلده القديمه من مدينه نابلس مشاهدينا
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اوضحت ايضا في
بيان المقتضب ان الكثير من الحالات مصابه
بالرصاص الحي كما ان القوات الاسرائيليه
كانت اقتحمت حاره الشيخ مسلم على اطراف
البلده القديمه من نابلس نشاهد المشاهدين
هذه الصور المباشره اذا من نابلس التي
اقتحمتها القوات الاسرائيليه فيما اكدت
الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل شخص واحد حتى الان
او مقتل فلسطيني واحد واصابه خمسه وعشرين
برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في نابلس في حي
الشيخ مسلم في اطراف البلده القديمه حيث
تقوم او تنفذ القوات الاسرائيليه عمليه
اقتحام لم تعرف اسبابها حتى هذه اللحظه
لكن هناك مواجهات كما نشاهد في هذه الصور
ايضا ربما جراء هذه المواجهات بين قوات
الاسرائيليه وبين الشبان الفلسطينيين في
هذا الحي في نابلس نؤكد مره اخرى مشاهدينا
بان الصحه الفلسطينيه اكدت حتى اللحظه
سقوط قتيل واحد واصابه خمسه وعشرين
فلسطينيا برصاص القوه الاسرائيليه في هذه
المواجهات
[موسيقى]
وما زلنا معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه
الصور كما تبدو تعكس اقتحام القوات
الاسرائيليه
لمدينه نابلس في حاره الشيخ مسلم على
اطراف البلده القديمه حيث تحاصر منزلا وسط
اطلاق نار كثيف ونشاهد ايضا سيارات
الاسعاف التي بدات تهرع الى المكان اضافه
الى مدرعات اسرائيليه واضحه في هذه الصوره
وسط مواجهات بين القوات الاسرائيليه
والشبان الفلسطينيين